good morning Hank it's Thursday it's
question Thursday the day that I answer
real questions from real nerdfighters
let's get right to it
how's the new book coming along in
general the less you hear me talking
about it the better it's going who do
you look up to most in the world my
parents and then secondarily Dwayne the
rock Johnson how do you want to be
remembered I'd like to be remembered
mostly as a father and a husband and a
sponsor of AFC Wimbledon what is your
response to critics who say your novels
are pretentious mmm do you have any
advice for it to cackle eat wait are we
talking about like running and jumping
decathlon or academic decathlon because
if it's running and jumping decathlon I
advise you to run fast and jump high or
far I don't really know the rules if
we're talking about academic decathlon I
advise you to specialize in art history
and economics can you juggle yes but
only tasks what's the weirdest animal
you've ever met hmm probably Maureen
Johnson what John Green quote are you
most proud of I'm pretty fond of
imagining the future is a kind of
nostalgia but it's not actually my line
it's something Sarah said to me on our
first date and I was like hold on a
second and I grabbed a napkin and I
wrote it down and I went home and put it
in Looking for Alaska I did ask for her
permission for the record how many
copies of Harry Potter do you own we
only have one copy of each book except
for book for which we have two copies of
this one was on Quentin's nightstand in
the Paper Towns movie if all the
characters in your books ran for
president which one would have your vote
I feel like Hazel's mom from The Fault
in Our Stars would be a pretty good
president you know like cool under
pressure
thoughtful cautious played by Laura Dern
favorite candy bar I mean guys come on
I'm literally sponsored by Snickers
favorite fictional place Hogwarts apple
pie or pumpkin pie pumpkin favorite
cheese
I've already go to Chipotle order
barbacoa salad no rice black beans extra
mild sausage just a little bit of cheese
and guacamole which yes I know it's
extra favorite Pizza John design that's
like asking me to pick between my
children I love them all differently but
equally what should I get my girlfriend
for our four year anniversary she
already got a pizza miss coffee mug for
our three year anniversary on your
recommendation I got a list here of all
the anniversary presents it says the
first year is paper your 50 is gold it
says here the year four is actually the
pizza John hoodie will you mentioned the
road to nerdfighteria yeah it's this
amazing project where nerdfighters
around the world talk about how they
found nerdfighteria link in the
doobly-doo would you ever consider
becoming president of the United States
no I would be very bad at that job and
it involves a lot of things I find very
unpleasant
shaking hands with strangers and asking
rich people for money John why aren't
you snap chatting so a few months ago I
turned my phone into a dumb phone that
does nothing but text make phone calls
and play pokemon go so I guess it's not
that dumb but this change in my life has
been kind of wonderful even if I do miss
snapchat a little how do you stay
informed about current events this is
another change I made about a year ago I
read The Economist the New York Times
The Wall Street Journal and my hometown
paper the Indianapolis Star I used to
think that reading whatever was on my
social media feed was the best way to
stay informed but now I've become a
little bit suspicious of that
proposition how do you feel about social
media anyway you know how sometimes
you're in a really intense romantic
relationship and you can kind of tell
that the candle is burning at both ends
and will not last the night and your
friends are like maybe you guys should
break up and you know maybe you should
but you're having a lot of fun and it's
not like you're gonna get married you
know I mean this isn't serious is it
yeah kind of like that why do you read
fiction two reasons really first for
consolation like I understand in the
abstract that I am NOT alone but reading
good fiction helps me feel unallowed in
like the deepest ways you know it makes
me feel like even my inexpressible fears
and demons don't separate me from
humanity and then secondly I think it's
nice and maybe even important to escape
the prison of your consciousness for a
while and try to live in someone else's
mind and for me reading stories is like
the most efficient way out of myself if
I make my question a reminder that pizza
miss ends tomorrow into all these
amazing pizza miss wonders are only
available for one more day at dftba.com
will you make it the last question yes
yes I will
Hank you'll see me on Tuesday